you'll notice all the action behind me
perhaps you're just hearing a lot of it
here in the hood room that's because
demo fest is in full swing here they
just opened up the doors a little while
ago folks swinging in here to the Mount
Hood room and we're very lucky to have
our very own one on one demo right here
from Microsoft development lead of the
tools for software engineers group
Nikolaj telling Nick live thanks for
being here I think it's gonna be fun I
got excited because I heard video game
and then they followed up with code into
my head started hurting but I know that
you can handle it
thanks for bringing in your demo for our
audience what do you have today so I'm
going to show indeed a game yeah there
you have to write code so it's called
code hunt and the idea is that you have
to write a particular algorithm to solve
puzzles okay so the background here is
that we have actually done a decade of
research on how to automatically test
programs so we have a tool for
professional developers that integrates
into the studio to automatically
generate test cases and that helps you
write better code fine box but it sounds
a bit boring right why in and I have to
wonder is this purely for enjoyment is
it for recruitment or is it for
education or for all of the above it's
all of the above so we took this
technology that we developed for serious
to help us and we turned it into
something that is fun and yet useful for
many other purposes as we discovered
like like recruiting and running
contests to find the best coder and the
word gotcha okay so I can just go ahead
show us the cover let's see how it all
starts from the website koat.com and
when you go to the side you see there's
a cool logo if you really made it look
like yeah the games that you play on
your phone and if you start going in
just tap on the play button then you can
select different levels and as you get
more skilled you can progress to two
different sectors let's start this
something that was simple the training
sure level and so what we see is there's
a program here some code and the goal of
the game is to write code in here that
first a secret puzzle that we don't know
the solution to yet okay and in the
background our test case generation
engine with the symbolic execution
theorem provers constrain so us lots of
sophisticated technology to see whether
your program is correct now what does it
really mean what is correct we don't
know beforehand and the only way to get
more knowledge about what this program
is supposed to do that we are writing
you have to press this button capture
code it invokes our analysis and you get
a table that shows you that for a
particular input for example here - one
hour recharge our code to each one zero
and so did the secret program that
returns the expected ratio everything is
good in this line but there's another
line where for the input zero we should
have returned one but with me return
zero because it's called over switch on
zero so what I can do now is go in and
looking at that one volt line I can
write an if statement if x is 0 then we
expect it to return 1 so I can refine my
program ask the system again and it says
I got it right for 0 but now there's
another very very long one so I can keep
writing these if statements and what
happens in under the hood our engine
actually analyzes the code every time
I'm writing an if statement it produces
a new test case and I can basically keep
doing this forever I can write more if
statements an IV never been what really
has to happen at this point I said we
try to see what is the general problem
that we are supposed to solve and
actually in this case of the only
statement and if you look closely then
it looks like you always supposed to
return one more than the input boss and
when you make that step such abstraction
step he can tries it so I can say in
general return X plus 1 and hopefully if
I got that right
come on yeah yeah Nikolai we're waiting
for the big so what are you do the
background is that's the problem is sent
to a cloud service sure which can give
us an opportunity number of people and
it's hard to figure out whether this
program is equivalent to a secret one
and when it is then you win so in
general if you go back to the game they
are different levels and they get more
and more difficult so later on there's
another one they don't have to come up
with X plus one that's kind of trivial
but you have to implement a sorting
algorithm so here's a puzzle that takes
an array and returns an array and we are
supposed to implement a sorting
algorithm in terms of right you see that
numbers are shuffled our arms so that's
really much more of a challenge and
people spend a lot of time doing this so
over time they actually adds quite a lot
of people who were playing the game
there's a leaderboard and you can see
Scioscia here are some people who got a
lot of points every time you win a level
you get some points the more elegant
coat your hose is some more points you
get
and some people spend a lot of time
trying to hone the programming skills
yeah so Nicola I gotta ask because when
I was a kid there was a talk in a movie
called The Last Starfighter about a kid
who lived in this remote area and he
played this video game and then he
became so good at it that it was a
crouppen tool I didn't know about it
they came down from space
they said you you're the Last
Starfighter you that you won this game
you're the best star fight so I have to
wonder is there any stories of somebody
who's done so well that you go knock at
the door and say hey you've got a
budding career here right you a coder
you should be does that I mean is that
that's one of the ideas behind cotons
this is a service provided by Microsoft
and recruiting is one area that we want
to use it already today whenever I have
to interview someone for a job
I make them solve a puzzle and it's out
there now you can go to koat.com and if
you're really really good we might
contact you
Wow yeah it's pretty cool so all of this
runs in in Windows Azure there's a
service behind it
if you're really good you cannot just
try to win the game you can actually
write a bot that automatically solve
such challenges so the opportunities are
limitless and how you can have fun in
this game right you can write code or
you could write an engine that writes
code Wow kind of created this whole
little web here disguised as a game look
at you well done thanks for showing us a
demo thank you thank you you get you
know there's a lot of people here you
can go recruit around there might be the
next great coder of the world right
behind us here yeah let me go out there
and catch a semi Nikolay thanks man we
appreciate it